this is breaking news
on eight news now
good morning i'm alex jackson i'm john
langley breaking news a murder suicide
investigation lessons into lieutenant
ray spencer
on a shooting investigation near
flamingo and mountain vista the
situation is a hostage
type situation due to the fact that the
male was refusing to let her leave and
she could be hurt she was heard crying
in the background on the phone
swat made entry into the residence and
found
the male deceased with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head
and also found the female suffering from
a gunshot wound
she was still alive at the time she left
the house the tactical doctor with the
swat
team attempted to render aid they
transported her to
sunrise trauma where she was pronounced
deceased due to the fact that this is a
murder-suicide with officers outside the
residence
we will provide a 72-hour briefing from
our executive staff
within the next three days we are
working diligently to try to open up
flamingo right now
due to the fact swat is now leaving with
hostage negotiators we expect to have
flamingo
opened within the next hour again i'm
not taking any questions this will be
for a
72 hour brief will be provided by
executive staff here in the next
three days yes if you're
ever in that situation what's the best
way to make sure that
no one dies like that what was the best
way to
prevent like what
well the roommate did a roommate did an
absolute phenomenal
thing in this situation she noticed he
was armed with a handgun
and took the child outside of the
residence that is the absolute
smartest thing that she could have done
in this situation so thank you